on réitère notre appui a raillé badaoui
on veut sa libération l'important c'est
de poursuivre la mobilisation
j'accueille maintenant béatrice
vaugrante d'amnesty international pour
le canada francophone bon sens alain
vaugrante
amnesty international qui publie son
rapport annuel sur les exécutions
aujourd'hui mais d'abord j'aimerais
avoir votre réaction sur ce qui s'est
passé aujourd'hui donc l'arabie saoudite
qui nous dit au fond ce qui se passe sur
le territoire de l'arabie saoudite
concerne l'arabie saoudite ne nous ne
vous mêlez pas de nos affaires il faut
surprendre faut surprendre déjà qu'ils
réagissent et c'est bien parce que
d'habitude ils ne réagissent pas donc là
l'ampleur de la campagne sur et de la
mobilisation pour la libération arrive
malawi les fait réagir c'est exactement
le même contenu du communiqué de presse
promu il ya quelques ya quelques
semaines de cela il ya deux choses à
dire on se mêle pas mais pourtant au
conseil des droits de l'homme dont ils
font partie il accepte toutes les
recommandations et il les accepte
vraiment des couvertures des pays qui
sont autour de la table donc ingérence
ou pas ingérence et on a toujours
deuxième raison on a toujours une un ton
très feutré avec l'arabie saoudite pour
une fois on essaye le bruit on essaye la
pression et ça peut peut-être
fonctionner parce qu'avant on peut aider
à oui je pense que oui parce qu'avant
malheureusement le fait de toujours nous
faire dire il faut faire très attention
même les états je dirais amis d'arabie
saoudite pour des raisons commerciales
ou politiques
cherchent eux aussi à se faire très
discret hélas non les contrats à se
bouger on les contraint à se prononcer
on voit la motion adoptée au parlement
aujourd'hui et oui c'est une bonne chose
parce que le silence n'a pas toujours
servi essayons donc le bruit donc
l'arabie saoudite qui fait partie je
reviens à votre rapport sur les
exécutions qui fait partie des cinq pays
où il ya le plus d'exécutions dans le
monde tout à fait donc trio de tête mais
main avec la chine l'iran l'arabie
saoudite en troisième et puis ensuite on
a eu raquer états unis le nom
d'exécution nous inquiète et surtout le
nombre je dirais d'augmentation des
condamnations à mort et on voit très
bien la lutte au terrorisme la lutte
donc pour la sûreté de l'état sécurité
du public pour des bonnes ou des
mauvaises
l'homme et saldo large pour beaucoup de
pays pakistan chine iran irak on a
recours à ces exécutions là pour
soi-disant donc remédier aux attaques
terroristes et on n'est pas certain que
ce soit la bonne réponse d'autres pays
comme l'arabie saoudite ou l'iran
l'utilisent pour tuer la dissidence
politique
mais donc quand même la bonne nouvelle
si on peut d'ailleurs de ce rapport
c'est quand même le nombre des
exécutions qui baissent kb slam
solidement douzaine de courses de 22% au
comptant les condamnations augmenté de
28% à cause entre autres nigeria egypte
qui font des condamnations collective
mais le nombre total d'exécution cette
année par rapport à une dernière a
baissé de 22% il ya de moins en moins
d'états qui ont recours à ce châtiment
là quand on a commencé en 77 y avait
seize est un abolitionniste
aujourd'hui il y en a cent quarante même
aux états unis la tendance est à la même
sagesse aux états unis ça reste une
pratique ça reste une pratique c'est
quand même déplorable que les états unis
côtoie la chine l'iran l'irak pour ce
pour ce rapport sur la peine de mort
mais maintenant il n'y a plus que cet
état aux états unis qui ont donc recours
à des exécutions l'année passée quatre
sont les irrémédiable compte pour 90 %
des exemples d exécution donc c'est sûr
cela qu'on va mettre aussi toute mon
envie notre mobilisation mais au niveau
du monde entier résolution de l'onu 117
pays résolution qui demande un moratoire
sur les exécutions c'est un chiffre
record ça nous encourage beaucoup un
petit peu d'espoir absolument merci
beaucoup à la main au grand merci à vous